joining us now is the former head of the
home civil service that's lord butler
hello my lord thank you so much for
joining us good morning how tricky is it
for civil servants when we have a sort
of
cat i'm being told not to call him a
caretaker prime minister but that's what
he is
well the job of the civil service is to
keep the show on the road
and so it's not really very tricky and
it's not a very long period um so um
during the next 10 days it is while
parliament's sitting and until it's
whittled down to the last two no there
shouldn't be any major decisions to be
taken and major decisions shouldn't be
taken
and then during
the period when the conservative party
is consulting in the country then
there's really only two candidates and
they can be consulted on any major
decisions that have to be taken
what about when uh we saw um ministers
dropping like flies last week were there
enough ministers 25 percent had gone
from the prime minister's government not
enough to run the country we were told
no absolutely not um and so a lot of
business couldn't go on there weren't
people to attend parliamentary
committees and so things
virtually ground to a stop but again um
there wasn't an awful lot to do
parliament goes into recess
in the summer and so you know you can
operate for quite a long time without
all the politicians being in place
as far as civil servants are concerned i
spoke to i don't know if you managed to
catch our interview uh it'll be online
as well with the present chancellor he
was saying that he had successfully
managed to cut 20 from the budget of uh
the running costs of the department of
education he wants to do that across the
whole of government in order to have
enough money for tax cuts um that would
mean job losses for civil servants
surely yes i i expect it would um and
when i was um private secretary to
margaret thatcher the civil service was
cut by a hundred thousand now it's not
impossible to do that
the question is how it's done and it
ought to be done with respect and with
care for the people who you're employing
um we did hear the prime minister um
talk about the peerless british civil
service when he made his speech that
we'll call a resignation speech last
week but he once tried to cut what 91
000 jobs in the civil service over the
cost of living crisis um
how important is it
to have a prime minister that is um duly
respectful of the staff around him well
it's very important um i always think of
gerald ratner you remember i do very
much and you don't get give leadership
you don't get loyalty you don't get
results if you don't treat your
employees with respect
when we talk about the civil service um
people at home this morning getting
ready for work were thinking what does
the civil service actually do and the
answer is you know that all sorts of
things they don't just work in offices
in whitehall here do they they work in
prisons they work all over the place yes
and it's their job to support the
government of the day to support its
policies and to carry them out as
efficiently as they can
and they are roles that are um
non-political that must be quite tricky
on occasion well of course i mean
government is about politics but you
mustn't take a partisan view so what
civil servants have to do is to work for
the government that the electors
produce
how difficult is the transition not only
from when you have one prime minister of
the same colour to another one uh you
know whoever the next conservative prime
minister will be but also when you have
a complete change of regime well it can
be a bit of a personal trauma yes i'm
sure so tell me more about that yeah
well you get very close to the person
you're working with i got very close to
john major and then tony blair came in
and then you just have to demonstrate
that you are going to do your best for
the new incumbent as professionally as
you can and you can usually build up
confidence about that quite quickly
this period you say it is a period of
transition but it's fairly
straightforward you think as far as the
civil servants are concerned are you
saying that it's just basically a
holding pattern they're marking time
what if the present prime minister
decides that he does want to push
through some major policy i don't know
on the northern ireland protocol while
this process is going through well it's
not a very long time
about six weeks maybe well six weeks but
only um ten days probably until we're
the last down to the last two candidates
and the prime minister shouldn't do that
he'd be advised not to do that by whom
by or by the head of the civil service
by the cabinet secretary not least
and ministers would be advised in a
similar way by the permanent secretaries
in their departments and i would expect
them to comply with that
and as far as just before i let you go
because i know you're terribly busy um
when we've seen what's been happening in
downing street over a period of time
during lockdown how much did you feel
for those civil servants that were
working there at the time
oh i i felt for them very acutely i mean
i think for everybody the covid was a
very difficult time and they were
working extremely hard but i was also
ashamed of some of the behavior that
went on in 10 downing street it
shouldn't have happened i don't believe
it would have happened when i was
working there because we had such
respect for
the institution for the government we
felt privileged to be there we felt
respect for the prime ministers who we
served
and the way sue grey was treated
well i think sue grey was put in a very
difficult position i don't think you
know a civil servant can ever really be
asked to
a judge on the behavior of
their boss
and so sue gray
produced the facts it wasn't for her to
produce a judgment i think she handled
it very well in a very difficult
situation and if the same situation or a
similar situation were to develop again
you don't think that it would be for a
civil servant to be find themselves in
that position so who who should um judge
on the prime minister's behavior it has
to be the cabinet
parliament and eventually the electorate
well let's see what happens good to talk
to you my lord thank you so much for
joining us much appreciated thank you